explore topics like the nature of
progress the growing sense of isolation
in the modern world and the shared
struggles of dealing with increasingly
invasive technology and social phenomena
in my new book millions of little
threads it's available as an audiobook
on the pursuit of Wonder website and now
it's also available on Audible as well
as as an ebook and paperback on Amazon
or if you're more interested in
nonfiction you can check out my book of
collected works called The Art of Living
a meaningless existence ideas from
philosophy that change the way you think
the links for both are in the
description below
one of the earliest phrases we must have
heard in that corrective parental tone
is be nice
Without Really knowing exactly what this
meant at the time we understood on some
level that what we were doing how we
were behaving and interacting with
another was not okay we were doing what
we wanted to or with this other person
but what we wanted was a problem
[Music]
As We Grew Older this guidance to be
nice continued to be facilitated and
reinforced from parents to teachers from
religious figures to cartoon aardvarks
and TV commercials about soda
in a world where there are awful people
where awful things happen where
existence and even its most basic
optimal form is filled with chaos and
hardship and suffering the guidance to
be nice and striving to be nice is
unequivocally a good thing
but for many of us this is about where
it ends and The crucial nuances of what
it means to be kind in a complicated
world and the potential consequences of
misunderstanding how to be are left
without further guidance or
clarification
of course nice is a relatively vague
term and subject to multiple definitions
and interpretations so to be clear
niceness here is to mean a sort of
substantial aversion to negatively
affecting others in any way a
willingness to always accommodate or
agree with others to say yes to be quiet
to put one's own views sensibilities and
Desires in second or last place
of course this definition May differ
from what some may hold the term to mean
but that is part of the problem niceness
is so easily misunderstood
this sort of niceness though it may seem
Pleasant on balance and over even a
relatively short period of time it's
harmful to all involved parties the
so-called nice person and everyone they
interact with
the consequences of this sort of
niceness might lead one to always say
that they like or agree with what
everyone else immediately around them
does it might lead one into jobs they
don't like working with or for people
and companies they don't agree with it
might lead one into Bad Business deals
or creative collaborations where one is
ignored at best or taken advantage of at
worst it might lead one to withhold
useful ideas or doubts that counter or
challenge other people involved in a
shared project or Endeavor it might lead
to one saying yes to every invite or
opportunity even when they aren't at all
what one wants to do and it might lead
one into Dreadful one-sided friendships
and relationships or to staying in
friendships and relationships that have
been long since over
generally the nice person's goal is
presumably to be nice but not only does
this sort of niceness open oneself up to
being taken advantage of misunderstood
misplaced and so forth but it is also a
sort of covert selfishness and
Unfaithful deception and truth always
agreeing with what a person says or
wants is not an affirmation that one
cares about what that person thinks or
wants but rather it is a demonstration
that one cares more about how others
think and feel about them it is a
sacrifice of an authentic and caring
interaction for the purpose of favorable
self-preservation the nice person is not
truly listening or responding to what is
being said or done or requested they are
performing a show for an audience they
so desperately want to be reviewed
favorably for
the nice person interacts and reacts to
others in specific ways not as an
authentic participant but as a means to
demonstrate or perform a favorable
appearance without concern for the
actual consequences or outcomes of their
performance
as a participant in friendships
relationships where collaborations and
Society at large we contribute
negatively by contributing falsely thus
this sort of niceness often isn't even
outwardly nice even if it comes from a
well-intended place
moreover as time passes the nice person
can only withstand misaligned or
disingenuous relationships and
arrangements for so long before a
resentment and displeasure is bound to
Harbor inside them which ultimately
either leads to impairing real
opportunities or causes a slow burn and
torturous prolonging of an inevitable
end
if we truly wish to be good and
meaningful contributors to our social
relations our work our self we must
recognize the different kinds of
niceness here we can refer to the more
optimal kind as kindness and what
kindness calls for is a reasonable
degree of authentic participation care
and honesty with others which often
necessitates disagreements and arguments
uncomfortable moments and conversations
and the termination of relationships and
circumstances that no longer work
telling someone bluntly how and why you
are frustrated with how they've upheld
or not upheld their side of an agreement
or collaboration or not agreeing to one
at all may not sound nice but it is and
it will be to you and to them telling a
partner how frustrated you are with
their unwillingness to meet you halfway
on reasonable compromises or preferences
may not be pleasant but in the long run
it is and it will be turning down
invitations or opportunities or deals
that you aren't interested in might not
feel very respectful or considerate but
it is and it will be telling a friend
that their actions and your opinion are
foolish or bothersome or unreasonable
may not feel nice but it is and it will
be and for those who can't see that it
is or don't stick around to try to or
work through it having that be the last
interaction with them may not seem very
fair or nice but it is and it will be we
must learn how and continually try to
trust that we can be okay without
certain people without the universal
approval and agreement of everyone
without every friendship or relationship
without every collaboration or invite or
deal think of all the time saved think
of all the Illusions and
misunderstandings and possible
divergences prevented think of all the
resentment and disdain and confusion
never harbored
of course none of this is to make light
of the difficulty of anything discussed
here nor is it to accuse guilt or shame
unto those who have or continue to act
with the sort of niceness the nice
person is most often just that a nice
person trying their best understandably
misguided and how to best go about it it
is a complicated World filled with
platitudes and contradictory instruction
and for many the problem is only further
exasperated or perhaps caused entirely
by a shattered sense of confidence which
has been shattered through no fault of
One's Own
we can understand this in others through
kindness and we can work through it in
ourselves through kindness
the kind that isn't always comfortable
or easy the kind that doesn't always
make you everyone's favorite but the
kind that is effective and chose a
willingness to turn one's positive
intentions and hopes into real positive
outcomes in the world
[Music]
Kennedy returned to his apartment and
sat by himself at his kitchen table he
ate while using the swap app he was
swapping with the famous wealthy man who
often hung out with attractive women and
lived what seemed like a luxurious
active lifestyle Kennedy didn't really
know why he did this he didn't care
about the man he didn't even really want
to be like the man and the experience
was often riddled with anxious and
depressive feelings but it was some
strange period curiosity that Kennedy
couldn't seem to help himself from
most of us can relate to this experience
in some capacity becoming absorbed and
almost possessed by technology or any
social phenomenon for that matter often
without even really thinking about it or
understanding why my new book millions
of little threads which that excerpt is
from explores topics like these how we
become alienated from ourselves as
individuals and as collectives how we
deal with and become victims to
increasingly passive modes of life and
what we experience personally as a
result of this the story is one hour
long and is just 3.99 as an audiobook on
the pursuit of Wonder website and now
it's also available on Audible as well
as as an ebook and paperback on Amazon
since so many of you have requested
those or if nonfiction is more your
preference check out my book of
collected works titled The Art of Living
a meaningless existence which attempts
to provide the value of motivation and
personal development without any of the
sugar coding often found in the modern
hyper-positive self-help genres and
instead through unwavering philosophical
honesty the links for both books are in
the description below to all those who
have already purchased and left
wonderful reviews thank you so much it
is sincerely appreciated and of course
as always thank you so much for watching
in general and see you next video
[Music]
thank you